thank you jillian it's easier than ever
to buy a used car in finley toyota the
sponsors of this next segment have
exactly what you're looking for
you know what they say about the best
new cars and trucks is that they make
the best used cars and trucks and here
at finley toyota they have a huge
selection of certified used vehicles hey
john good to see you buddy good to see
you my friend so what makes your
certified used vehicle so special well
certified cars can only come from a
toyota dealer and with our cars what
happens is we get the selection of the
best available used cars because they
come back and buy a new one which is
great so we have a selection that
cutters beyond anybody else's
imagination what do we have here this is
a hybrid camry this 2018 toyota camry
hybrid in super white can get an
estimated 53 highway miles per gallon
efficiency never looks so good and john
what do we have here this is toyota rav4
this 2019 limited edition rav4 comes
with navigation sunroof heated seats and
features all-wheel drive for endless
adventures john these vehicles look
practically brand new what do we have
here this is a toyota 4runner this 2019
ford runner features leather seats
premium trim navigation system satellite
radio and is an off-road lover's dream
john what kind of inspection goes into
these vehicles before they hit the line
there's a whole procedure that goes
through but you know what rather than me
trying to tell you about it why don't we
go back and see we'll go to service all
right i know the way you're happy you're
the man let's go
we're off
i'm not left here there we go
first past the thing first
doors
right
hi i'm jay tonell
i'm a high-end used car master
technician and a toyota master tech this
engine looks very clean do you guys
clean the engine absolutely everything
gets going through our detail shop after
it's done being reconned here in the
shop jay we surfing the internet here
what are we doing buddy no what we're
doing is we're actually talking to the
car talking to the car with our computer
yes we are this is toyota's tech stream
this is the interface unit to talk to a
toyota vehicle
today's vehicles can have anywhere from
35 to 100 on board computers
this particular car has about 60.
so what the tech stream does is it runs
everything through a quick check and
lets us know if the vehicle has any
codes in any of the systems so you're
asking the car are you okay and the car
is saying back yes i'm okay or no i
might need this fixed it will point out
things that are not
up to the parameters that toyota has set
forth wow that's awesome jay what are we
looking for underneath the truck we just
want to make sure that there's no leaks
and the biggest thing is we want to make
sure this vehicle has not been involved
in an accident we want to make sure it's
safe and ready to go for the customer
this thing again looks brand new with
the undercarriage you guys clean this at
all yes actually our detail shop make
sure this is nice and clean for the new
owner okay i say a pass inspection can i
have the honors of dropping this thing
back down on the ground absolutely let's
drop it over here over here let's do it
this 4runner has passed inspection so if
you're in the market for a certified
used vehicle finley toyota is the place
to go
thank you again to findlay toyota for
sponsoring this segment you can check
out all of their certified used vehicles
online at findlaytoyota.com
visit them at 7733 east gate road in
henderson or just call 702-566-2596